Ou nous décidons ce que nous allons faire pour prévenir la démence,
et ça ne nous arrivera jamais parce que nous allons faire tout ce qu'il faut et elle ne s'emparera pas de nous.
Je cherche une troisième possibilité : je me prépare à être atteinte de la maladie d'Alzheimer.
La prévention est une bonne chose, et je fais ce que l'on peut faire pour prévenir l'Alzheimer.
Je mange bien, je fais de l'exercice tous les jours, je garde mon cerveau actif,
c'est ce que la recherche nous dit de faire.
Mais la recherche montre aussi que rien ne vous protègera à 100%.
Si le monstre vous veut, le monstre vous aura.
C'est ce qui est arrivé à mon père.
Mon père était bilingue, c'était un professeur de faculté. Ses passe-temps étaient les échecs, le bridge et la rédaction d'éditoriaux d'opinion.
(Rires)
Il a quand même été atteint de démence.
Si le monstre vous veut, le monstre vous aura.
Surtout si vous êtes dans mon cas, parce qu'Alzheimer a tendance à être héréditaire.
Je me prépare donc à avoir la maladie d'Alzheimer.
D'après ce que j'ai appris en m'occupant de mon père,
et en faisant des recherches sur ce que c'est que de vivre avec une démence, je me concentre sur trois choses dans ma préparation :
je change ce que je fais pour m'amuser, je cherche à renforcer ma force physique,
et, le plus dur, j'essaie de devenir une personne meilleure.
Commençons par les passe-temps. Quand vous avez une démence, il devient de plus en plus dur de vous amuser.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous assoir pour de longues conversations avec vos vieux amis, parce que vous ne savez plus qui ils sont.
Regarder la télévision vous perturbe, et souvent vous effraie.
Et lire est quasiment impossible.
Quand vous vous occupez d'une personne atteinte de démence, et que vous recevez une formation pour le faire,
on vous apprend à les impliquer dans des activités qui sont familières, manuelles, flexibles.
Avec mon père, ce fut de le laisser remplir des formulaires.
Il était professeur dans une faculté d'état ; il sait à quoi ressemble la paperasse.
Il va signer son nom sur toutes les lignes, il va cocher toutes les cases,
il va mettre des chiffres là où il pense qu'il doit y en avoir.
Mais ça m'a fait réfléchir, qu'est-ce que le personnel de soin me donnerait à faire ?
Je suis la fille de mon père. Je lis, j'écris, je réfléchis beaucoup aux questions de santé dans le monde.
Est-ce qu'on me donnerait des revues scientifiques pour que je fasse des gribouillis dans la marge ?
Est-ce qu'on me donnerait des tableaux et des graphiques à colorier ?
J'essaye donc d'apprendre à faire des choses avec mes mains.
J'ai toujours aimé dessiner, alors je le fais plus souvent même si je dessine très mal.
J'apprends les bases de l'origami. Je sais faire une super boîte.
(Rires)
Et j'apprends à tricoter toute seule, pour l'instant je sais faire un truc informe.
Mais vous savez, que je sois douée ou non n'a pas d'importance. Ce qui compte c'est que mes mains sachent quoi faire.
Parce que plus il y a de choses qui me sont familières, plus il y a de choses que mes mains savent faire,
plus il y aura d'activités que je pourrai être heureuse et occupée à faire quand mon cerveau ne sera plus aux commandes.
On dit que les gens qui se plongent dans des activités sont plus heureux,
plus faciles à prendre en charge pour les personnels de santé, et que ça peut même ralentir l'avancée de la maladie.
Ça me parait être tout bénéfice.
Je veux être aussi heureuse que possible aussi longtemps que possible.
Beaucoup de gens ne savent pas qu'Alzheimer a en fait des symptômes physiques,
en même temps que cognitifs. On perd le sens de l'équilibre,
les muscles tremblent, et ça a tendance à rendre les gens de moins en moins mobiles.
Ils ont peur de marcher. Ils ont peur de bouger.
Je fais donc des activités qui renforcent mon sens de l'équilibre.
Je fais du yoga et du tai chi pour améliorer mon sens de l'équilibre, de sorte que lorsque je commencerai à le perdre,
je puisse encore me déplacer.
Je soulève des poids, pour renforcer mes muscles,
pour que lorsque je commencerai à décliner, je puisse bouger plus longtemps.
Finalement, la troisième chose. J'essaye de devenir une meilleure personne.
Mon père était gentil et affectueux avant d'avoir Alzheimer, et il est gentil et affectueux aujourd'hui.
Je l'ai vu perdre son intellect, son sens de l'humour, ses compétences linguistiques,
mais j'ai aussi vu ceci : il m'aime, il aime mes fils,
il aime mon frère, ma mère et les personnes qui s'occupent de lui.
Et cet amour nous donne envie d'être près de lui, même maintenant,
même quand c'est si difficile.
Quand tout ce qu'il a jamais appris dans ce monde lui est enlevé,
son cœur nu continue à briller.
Je n'ai jamais été aussi gentille que mon père, ni aussi affectueuse.
Et ce dont j'ai besoin à présent, c'est d'apprendre à être comme ça.
J'ai besoin d'un cœur si pur que si la démence m'enlève tout, il survivra.
Je ne veux pas avoir la maladie d'Alzheimer.
Ce que je veux c'est un remède dans les 20 prochaines années, assez tôt pour me protéger.
Mais si ça m'arrive, je serai prête.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)